Vinh free temple is heading home he
spent his childhood in the now infamous
Colonia Dignidad cult 20 years of
beatings physical labor and
psychological abuse it's not a place I
want to go back to it's kind of like a
job that's uncomfortable for me I try to
limit my visits to two or three days at
a time it's difficult and mentally
exhausting being there
the former cult compound is now called
villa Bavaria or Bavarian village the
gates are kept closed just like when
hempel lived here behind these fences
Powell Schaefer a German immigrant ruled
supreme in the 1950s he was wanted by
authorities in Germany on abuse charges
he fled to Chile where he found it
Colonia Dignidad at first the compound
was held up as an idyllic slice of
German life but for 40 years these walls
hid stories of abuse torture and murder
the villas residents call themselves
colonist and there are still around 70
who call the compound home a hotel and
restaurant are located on the same
ground where Schaefer once abused his
followers the cult leaders house is
still standing now it's used as a music
school and prayer room but the residents
tore down the bathroom where Schaefer
abused dozens of young boys today van
three temple works as a lawyer in
Santiago he's suing both the German and
chilean governments on behalf of the 90
remaining victims of Colonia Dignidad
like Harold Lindemann Paul Shaffers
bedroom was behind this door every night
another boy was scheduled to work here
in other words spend the night with him
it's not something you want to think
about
Pawel Schafer's abuse touched almost all
the men in the colony most were young
and cut off from their families easy
prey for the experienced abuser the
lingering trauma inflicted by Schaffer
still causes problems for many of his
clients including for helmet bono and
his wife they're hoping the lawsuit that
temple has prepared will help them start
a new life I didn't know my father
mother or my siblings that's what we
want to change our fate we want to show
that we can be a real family despite
what happened Helmut blames both Germany
and Chile for what he suffered many of
Colonia Dignidad residents were dual
citizens we had two passports and that
means two court systems as well the
German and the Chilean and both of them
failed us didn't free temple and : Oh a
friend better are helping others learn
about what they experienced a recent
film has rekindled the question of who's
to blame for the abuse German Foreign
Minister frank-walter Steinmeier has
admitted Germany made mistakes in the
Colonia Dignidad case both countries
have done little to expose the full
extent of the cults crimes temple
represents the colonists for free he
says he only wants to see justice done
I'm amazed by VIN Floyd's fight he
decided all alone to fight for the
victims he has so much energy and keeps
fighting because you can never give up
the fight
temple plans to formally sue Chile than
to expand his case to Germany his fight
for justice for the colonist continues